معنى الانا حول هذا الموضوع من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك العميد الياس حنا
نريد ان نفهم اولا خريطه هذه التقدمات على
الجانبين يعني في وقت تقدم فيه
الاوكرانيون في خيرسون يتقدم فيه القوات
المواليه لروسيا في الدنيا كيف يمكن ان
نفهم هذه التقدمات على الجانبين
او الضفه الغربيه لنهر
ليس هناك من يعني هجومات وانجازات يعني
هناك ديناميه مختلفه يعني نتحدث عن الشرق
نتحدث عن الزفاف وكريمينا هناك محاوله
اوكرانيه للتقدم باتجاه سوف بتكلمين او
السيطره على الخط او الهاي واي كما يقال
البي 7 وهذا امر هناك هجمات عكسيه وايضا
هناك جنبا همم في محمود المعركه الكبرى
ولكن كل هذه الامور تدور على ما يقارب
مسافه بين ال 10 و30 كلم مهم اما في دنياك
فهذا امر مهم جدا للرئيس لانه يعتبرها
احدى اهم اقليم الدباس يعني الهدف الرئيسي
كان له اقليم الدباس
والهدف هو هذا الموضوع اما منطقه الجنوب
بعد الانسحاب من مدينه خرسون هناك عمليه
دفاعيه مهمه
باتجاه ذا فروجيا وخاصه كما ورد في
التقرير مدينه ميلتو بول المهمه جدا جدا
جدا ايمان
الروسي على تدمير البناء التحتيه في تلك
المناطق والبنا تحتيه للطاقه على وجه
الخصوص كيف يمكن ان يخدم القوات الروسيه
او الروس يعني هذا التدمير للبناء التحتيه
العمليات
يعني هو عمليه جعل الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يقاتل على الجبهه ليس قادرا او ليس لديه
دعم في العمق السياسي الاجتماع
هذه الاراده للقتال وبالتالي اختبار للغرب
الى اي مدى قد ينجح الغرب في الاستمرار
بدعم اوكراني ولكن علمنا التاريخي معا انه
كلما قصفت الشعب كلما تكتل الشعب حول
الحكومه الهدف منها استغلال هذا الوضع
وعسكرت ما يسمى باللاجئين يعني النازحين
اليوم هناك سته ملايين شخص بدون طاقه بدون
مياه وبدون تدفئه وهذا امر مشكله يشكل
مشكله على القياده في كاف وهو عكس ما
تريده روسيا اشكرك العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
بيروت